[Music]
Uh let's talk about some of the
interesting things we've learned uh over
time.
Um so the first thing is I think it's
super important for you to uh understand
and define um whether evals are actually
providing value uh for your organization
or not. Um and I tried to come up with
three signs that you should look for um
that that are good. Uh so the first is
um if a new model comes out uh you
should be prepared um uh via your evals
to be able to launch an update to your
product within 24 hours that
incorporates the new model. Uh Sarah
from Notion um she talked yesterday she
talked about this um specifically but um
for the past several model releases
every time something comes out Notion's
able to incorporate um the new model
within 24 hours. And I think that's a
really good sign of success. If you
can't do that, um, then it means that,
uh, you have some work to do on your
emails.
Um, another sign of success is if a user
complains about something, do you have a
very clear and straightforward path to
take their complaint and add it into
your evals? Um, if you do, then you have
a shot at actually um, incorporating
user feedback, pulling it into your
emails, and ultimately doing it better.
If you don't, then you're going to lose
a lot of valuable information into the
ether. Uh so again I think this is a
really important kind of threshold or
milestone to hit.
Um and the last one which I'm actually
going to talk about a little bit more
throughout the presentation is um you
should really start using evals to play
offense and understand which use cases
you can solve um and how well you can
solve them before you actually ship
things not like unit tests which allow
you to just test for regressions. Um,
and so if you if you really adopt EVELs,
then I think uh before you launch a new
product, you have a really good idea of
how well the product might work given
what your EVLs say.
Um, the second lesson is that great eval
uh they have to be engineered. They
don't just come for free with uh
synthetic data sets and random LLM as a
judge scores that you read about online.
Um, and I think there's maybe two ways
of thinking about this. Um, there's no
data set that is perfectly aligned with
reality. I think in the cases that there
are, there's like basically nothing to
do and the use cases already work, which
there are a few that that are kind of
like that, like solving competition math
problems for example. But for most real
world use cases, any data set that you
can come up with ahead of time is not
going to represent what users are
actually experiencing. And I think um
the best data sets are those that you
can continuously reconcile um as you
actually experience what happens in
reality. And doing that well requires
quite a bit of engineering. Um of course
brain trust can help you with that. But
I think the the point is you have to
think about uh a data set as an
engineering problem not just something
that's given to you.
And the same is true with scorers. I
think um a lot of people we talk to ask
hey what scorers does brain trust come
with and and how can we use those uh so
that we don't need to think about
scoring and we actually have a really uh
powerful um open source library called
auto evals but it's very open- source
and uh uh flexible for a reason which is
that um every company that we work with
that's sufficiently advanced is writing
their own scoring functions um and
modifying them uh constantly and I think
uh one way to think about scores is
they're like a spec or like a PRD for
your AI application. And if you think
about them that way, um, one, it it
actually justifies making an investment
in scoring beyond just using something
off the shelf. And two, hopefully it's
fairly obvious that if you just use, you
know, an open- source or generic scorer,
that's a spec for someone else's
project, not yours.
Um, there's been a real shift towards
context in prompts that's not just the
system prompt that you write. And I
actually think that um just traditional
prompt engineering pe people say this in
different ways, but I think traditional
prompt engineering is evolving quite a
bit and it's very important to think
about context, not just a prompt. Um so
this um is an example of what kind of a
modern prompt looks like for an agent.
Usually you have a system prompt and
then a for loop which you know uh runs
LLM calls uh issues tool calls,
incorporates the tool calls into the
prompt and then iterates and iterates.
Um, and I I actually took a few uh um uh
uh trajectories from agents that that we
see in the wild and summarized these
numbers. And as you can see, a vast
majority of the tokens in the average
prompt um are not from the system
prompt. And so, yes, it's very important
to write a good system prompt and
continue to improve it. But if you're
not very precise about uh how you define
tools and how you define their outputs,
uh then you're leaving a lot on the
table. And I think one of the most
important things we've learned uh
together with some customers is that um
you can't just take tools as a
reflection of your APIs or your product
as it exists today. You have to think
about tools in terms of what the LLM
wants to see um and how you can use you
know exactly what you uh present to the
LLM to make it work really well. And I
think that in most projects um it's
actually very disruptive when you write
good tools. Um it's not something that's
just like an API layer on top of the
stuff that you already have. And the
same is true with their outputs. Um
there's one example that we uh worked on
recently for an internal project where
um shifting the output of a tool from
JSON to YAML actually made a significant
difference. And I know that's a little
bit of a meme in the AI universe, but
it's just so much more token efficient
and easy for an LLM to look at um a YAML
shaped data while doing analysis than
extremely verbose JSON. Um now, if
you're writing code and you're plugging
something into, you know, a charting
library, it makes no difference because
to JavaScript, YAML and JSON are both
structured data. Um but to an LLM,
they're very different. And so I think
you have to be very very thoughtful
about um you know how you actually
construct the definition of a tool and
how you construct its output for the LLM
to maximally benefit from it.
So I think one of the most important
things we've learned um and actually I I
would credit some of the folks at Replet
uh for really uh pioneering this
pattern. Um but you know every time a
new model comes out uh everything might
change. Um and I think you need to
engineer your product, engineer your
team, um engineer your you know mindset
so that when a new model comes out if it
changes everything for you, you can jump
on that opportunity and and ship
something that maybe wasn't possible
before. Um and I'm going to show you
some numbers uh for a product uh feature
that we're actually launching and I'm
going to show you a little bit of it
today. Um, but uh we we've had an eval
for a while that tells us how well this
feature might work and we run it every
few months and you can see you know it
wasn't uh that long ago that GPT40
was the best model out there. Um but but
things have changed uh and you know
progressively uh GPT41 did a little bit
better. Uh 37 sonnet is much better and
and for sonnet is actually even more
remarkably better. Um and uh what what
that's meant for us is that this feature
that um you know at 10% would would
really not be viable for our users to
use suddenly becomes viable. Um and so
you know Cloud 4 sonnet actually came
out two weeks ago. Um and we're shipping
the first version of this feature today
which is just two weeks later. But we
were able to jump on that opportunity
because we ran this eval. Um we were
ready to do it and we we saw that okay
great we've actually finally crossed uh
this threshold. Um so everyone that I
personally work with or talk to I
encourage to create evals that are very
very ambitious and um likely not uh uh
viable with today's models and construct
them in a way that when a new model
comes out you can just plug the new
model in and try it. Um, in Brain Trust,
we have this tool called the Brain Trust
proxy. Um, there's a lot of of similar
tools. You could use ours or you could
use something else. Uh, but really the
point is that you don't need to change
any code to work across model providers.
And so, um, you know, Google just
launched the newest version of of uh,
Gemini. Um, actually Gemini 2.5 Pro0520
scores 1% on this benchmark. Uh, so we
didn't even put it on here. Um, but
maybe the thing they launched today
actually uh does a lot better. We can
find out, you know, with with just a few
keystrokes maybe right after this talk.
Um, and the last thing is it's super
important if you uh think about um
optimizing your prompts to optimize the
entire system. Um so that means uh
thinking holistically about your um AI
system as the data that you use for your
evals, the task which is you know the
prompt, the agentic system, tools etc
and the scoring functions and and every
time you think about making um you know
your your app better you need to think
about improving this overall system. Um
we actually ran a benchmark uh which is
uh the same benchmark that I showed
previously. um it autooptimizes prompts
uh using um an LLM and uh we ran it once
by just giving it the prompt and saying
like hey please optimize the prompt and
a second time giving it the prompt the
data set and the scores and said please
optimize this whole system. Um and you
can see there's a very dramatic
difference. So again um something goes
from unviable to viable. Um, but it's
just super important to optimize the
entire system, not not just the prompt.
And actually, uh, this is, uh, a new
product feature that we are starting to
launch today. Um, if you're a Brain
Trust user, uh, you can go to the
feature flag section of Brain and turn
on a new feature flag called loop. Um
and uh the loop is this amazing cool new
feature that actually autooptimizes
uh your eval um directly within brain
trust. Uh so uh you can work in our
playground and um give it you know a
prompt uh a data set um and some scores
and it can actually create prompts, data
sets and scores too um and just you know
work with it. Uh the kinds of things
that we've seen work really well are
optimize this prompt or uh what am I
missing from this data set that would be
really good to test for this use case?
Um why is my score so low? Um or why is
my score so high? Can you please help me
write a score that is uh you know
harsher than the one that I have right
now? Um you can also try it out with
different models. So, uh, as you could
see from this, uh, we've definitely seen
the best performance with Cloud 4 Sonnet
and Cloud 4 Opus performs a couple of
percentage points better. Um, but we
encourage you to try it out with
different models. You can use 03, you
can use 04 mini, you can use Gemini,
maybe you're building your own uh, LLM
or fine-tune model. You can try that as
well. Um, and yeah, we're very excited
uh, for this. I think uh, I'm going to
talk about this a little bit later. Um,
and I'm happy to do it with some Q&A as
well, but um, I actually I really think
that the workflow around evals is going
to dramatically change now that LLMs are
capable of looking at prompts and
looking at data and actually making um,
you know, constructive improvements
automatically. A lot of the manual labor
that went into iterating with EVELs um,
doesn't need to be there anymore. So,
it's it's really exciting. Uh, we're
excited uh, to ship this and and to
start to get some feedback.
Uh so just to recap um five lessons that
I think are really important. Um
effective eval speak for themselves.
It's it's important to understand
whether you've kind of reached a point
of eval competence in your organization
or not. It's okay if you haven't. Um
it's not easy, but it's important to be
honest about that and work towards it.
Um when you're working on evals, it's
very important to engineer the entire
system. So don't just think about the
prompt. Don't just think about improving
the prompt. Please don't just use
synthetic data or hugging face data
sets. I know they're awesome, but please
use more than just that. Please don't
use off-the-shelf scores only. Write
your own. Think very deliberately about
um how you can craft the spec of what
you're working on into your scoring
functions.
Um think very carefully about context.
And I think in particular um what helps
me personally is to think about writing
tools uh like I would think about
writing a prompt. It's my opportunity to
communicate with an LLM and set it up
for success. And how I define the API
interface of the tool and I define its
output has a very dramatic impact on
that.
Make sure that you're ready for new
models to come out and to just change
everything. Um, so if a if a new model
comes out, you want to be prepared to
know that immediately, ideally the day
that it comes out. Um, and also be
prepared to like rip out everything and
replace it with a fundamentally new
architecture that takes advantage of
that new model. And I think part of that
is obviously having the right eval. Part
of it is engineering your product in a
way that actually allows you to do that.
And then finally when you think about
optimizing or improving uh your eval
performance um you have to think about
optimizing the whole system the data and
how you get that data the task itself um
which you know the prompt tools etc and
the scoring functions
and with that uh we have some time for
Q&A.
>> Yeah there's uh two microphones up here
one on the left side one on the right
side. uh feel free to stand up and ask
your questions.
>> Hi, this is Joti. Um, one of your slides
said take feedback and turn it into an
eval.
Are you concerned about overfitting
evals at that point where every feedback
then turns into an eval?
>> Oh, that's a great question. Um, also
nice to see you. Um so uh the question
was um one of the slides was about
taking feedback uh from you know real
data and adding it to a data set and
incorporating it in an email. Are you
worried about overfitting? Um and I
think the answer is I'm actually way
more worried about overfitting to the
data set without the user's feedback
than I am to um adjusting the fit to
incorporate the user's feedback. Like
the most important thing about a data
set is not the state of the data set at
any point in time. It is how well you
are equipped to reconcile the data set
with the reality that you want. Um and I
actually think one of the things that we
discourage uh in the product and some
people complain to us about this. I get
it uh if you're one of those people. Um
but we don't automatically take user
feedback and add it to data sets right
now. We actually want a human who has
some taste and maybe uh can build some
intuition about the problem to find the
uh data points from users that are
interesting and add them to the data
set. And I think that is your
opportunity as a user to apply some
judgment about like oh okay this user is
trying to do something that should
obviously work. It's really sad that it
doesn't work in my product. Let me add
it to the data set so I can make sure it
does. Excuse me.
You had a slide I think in the tool
descriptions about like with some
percentages on it. Yeah, this one.
>> What what is that?
>> Yeah. So, um we took a few agents um
like we you know have a lot of traces uh
and we analyzed the relative um number
of tokens for different message types.
So the system prompt is one message
type. Tool definitions um are you know
the spec of what uh tools the model can
call. user and assistant um uh are um
tokens from user and assistant just text
interactions and then tool responses are
um tokens from the that you know that
the tool generates itself.
>> Oh this is the percentage of tokens
>> correct and this is the relative
percentage of those tokens. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. So the the the the point
that we're trying to make here is that
um I think in modern agentic systems uh
tools actually like very very
significantly dominate the token budget
of the LLM. And I think that it's very
important to um think about how you
define the definition of tools and how
you define their outputs so that you u
you know engineer the LLM for success.
uh not just sort of take you know your
GraphQL API and give it as a bunch of uh
you know uh tool calls to to the LLM.
>> Um first off that point about the thumbs
down is such a good point. I'm working
with the government and people don't
like the answer they got for example
about taxes and they give it a thumbs
down.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. So like adding that human aspect
is a really good idea. We actually even
added a little thing that said the
answer is right, but I just don't like
it.
>> That's awesome.
>> Um, but my question is about your point
that the new model changes everything.
We've updated our models several times
and and use code and open AAI and we
haven't found huge differences other
than recently someone really cheap
wanted to use 4.1 mini and like it
seemed to ignore every it. I swear it
ignored the system prop completely.
>> Yeah.
>> But what kind of things when you say it
changes everything, can you tell me a
little more about what kind of changes
you're seeing?
>> For sure. I think um the use case that
we just shipped with loop is a really
good example of that. So this is a very
ambitious uh agent. It's looking at
prompts and uh data sets and scores and
automatically optimizing the prompts
based on the data sets and scores. And
this is something that um you know we
wrote a benchmark for a while ago and we
ran with every consecutive model launch
and the numbers looked more like what
you see for GPT40 for a very long time.
This isn't true for every benchmark. So
um as part of this exercise we actually
have a bunch of uh evals that loop
optimizes. That's our eval set. And
there's some evals like uh classifying
taking movie quotes and figuring out
what movie they're coming from that have
worked really well since GPT 3.5. Um and
so there are certain use cases where it
just doesn't matter. There are other use
cases where um they're so ambitious that
they just don't work today. And I think
you want to create evals uh so that if
there's something ambitious that you
want to do in the future, you are very
well prepared when a new model comes out
to just push a button and find that out.
>> Okay. Thank you.
[Music]